welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Carol Armstrong a professor of art
history at Yale professor Armstrong
teaches and writes about 19th century
French painting the history of
photography the history and practice of
art criticism feminist theory and the
representation of women and gender in
art and visual culture she has published
books and essays on Degas MANET Cezanne
and 19th and 20th century photography
and has curated several museum
exhibitions she is an art critic and has
been a frequent contributor to October
and art forum magazines
she is also a practicing photographer
today we'll talk with professor
Armstrong about her book project seasons
gravity welcome professor Armstrong
thank you and thank you for inviting me
of course so let's begin with your book
please give us an overview of it okay
just to be very brief it's about the
after lives of the painter Paul Cezanne
who is generally held to be the father
of modernist
that is to say 20th century abstraction
it's a book that pairs Cezanne or in
some cases put Cezanne together with two
or more other figures with a variety of
different kinds of of writers and
thinkers from the 20th century beginning
with the poet Rainer Maria Rilke who
wrote letters to his sculptor wife about
Cezanne when he saw his work in the 1907
autumn salon which was a one of the sort
of array of different exhibitions annual
and biannual exhibitions that were
replacing the old
the old state-sponsored sounds then it
proceeds with a with a chapter that's
dedicated to Cezanne and his
relationship to with the Bloomsbury
figure Roger Fry who was also involved
with Virginia Woolf and her paint her
sister Vanessa Bell Frye was responsible
for the term post-impressionism
with an exhibition in London in nineteen
nineteen ten that featured Cezanne among
among others is the kind of father of a
new era of art but he wrote a book about
Cezanne in 1927 which was the year in
which Virginia Woolf also published her
breakthrough novel to the to the
lighthouse which is a woman painter the
third chapter from which I get the title
for the book is about Cezanne and
Einstein as the sort of on the one hand
the father of a paradigm shift in art
and the father of a paradigm shift in
science that weinstein never never
actually wrote about Cezanne in any way
and fourth chapter is about Cezanne and
the French philosopher merleau-ponty who
wrote extensively about about Cezanne
beginning in 1945 and then the final
chapter is concerned with Cezanne and
various figures in the psychoanalytic
and neuro neuroscience discipline from
the early 20th century on to the to the
present time okay and what led you to
write the book a number of things I had
done an exhibition on Cezanne and
written a book that went with it at the
at the getty back in 2004
I wasn't sure that I wanted to write a
monograph on Cezanne but but I did want
to come back in a kind of selective way
to to say sounds very groundbreaking
work
I wanted to extricate Cezanne from how
he's been normalized as as a sort of
father of abstraction and go back and
look at the and recover the strangeness
of seasons seasons work and then I also
wanted to use Cezanne to reconsider and
perhaps rethink the timelines of of 20th
century art into which he's been okay so
when you say the strangeness of his work
what do you mean well in in thinking
about Cezanne as a as the sort of father
of abstraction people have tended I
think to his to see his work as going in
the direction and leading sort of
inevitably to abstraction and so they
focused on a kind of 20th century
understanding of of Cezanne as really
interested in the sort of flatness of
the picture plane and and really
thinking in advance of abstraction and
that that's led to understanding him as
a kind of pre cubist pre abstract figure
and I think that's not adequate to to an
understanding of Cezanne I need I think
we really need to go back and sort of
understand the the peculiarity of his
work the strangeness of the spaces that
he crate creates the strangeness of the
the sort of points of view the way in
which objects are peculiarly warped the
very peculiar relationship between
objects and space that we find in his
work among other things okay so you
mentioned Virginia Woolf Einstein and
then the realm of the neuro cognitive
processing how do those all relate
okay well since these are all about this
after lives of of Cezanne sort of three
out of five of the chapters are
concerned with people who actually wrote
figures who actually wrote and/or we're
thinking about Cezanne two of the
chapters are concerned with with the
chapter on Einstein and the chapter on
psychoanalysis and and neuro cognitive
processing are concerned with figures
who didn't actually write about Cezanne
so there's a more indirect connection
but in all cases we are looking at the
afterlife but the afterlife of this of
this painter sort of phenomenally
influential painter as sort of thought
about from a fresh point of view to
emphasize the peculiarity of the of the
work Virginia Woolf is interested and
was interested as was Roger Fry they art
critic and curator and sort of
rethinking the the timelines of
modernity and the experience of time in
modernity and I want to argue about
Cezanne that that he too makes us think
about the that time of the painting or
of of our history differently as well as
for the narrow cognitive processing it
has more recently been argued by a
number of figures who work in so-called
neuro art history or neuro
esthetics that we can look at Cezanne
and famous aspects of his work like the
unfinish of his paintings the fact that
they leave parts of the canvas bare then
you can see some parts of the canvas
will look more
pleat and other parts will have sort of
brush work that is very loosely related
to a motif that you can recognize so
it's been argued that that we can look
at his work in relation to cognitive the
processes of how the brain makes sense
of the world I'd like to take a look
back at those ideas from the vantage
point of the philosopher merleau-ponty
who suggested very hypothetically in
1945 that Cezanne may have been schizoid
which was a term and an idea that was
circulated beginning to circulate in the
fields of psychology and and
psychoanalysis based on what based on
the oddity of his work and also certain
oddities of his of his biography it's
merleau-ponty was a philosopher of of
something called phenomenology and part
of the 1945 essay which was called
saisons doubt was to kind of revisit and
and sort of rethink our ideas about the
relationship between an artist's life
and their and their work so it's a
hypothesis which he's very clear cannot
be a diagnosis but which depends upon a
kind of strange relationship between the
things that Cezanne is representing and
the kind of unfolding way in which they
are represented has Cezanne ever written
or has anyone written for him his
thoughts what he was thinking when he
was painting yeah there was a lot of of
writing Cezanne zone letters were
collected and towards the end of his
life he was he became a kind of
apocryphal figure he went from being
someone who
next to Van Gogh was the least
successful in terms of selling work or
receiving critical or in terms of
critical success in the Parisian art
market he for the most of his life kept
in his hometown of Exxon Provence he was
but he was known for sort of sayings of
rather poor rather sphinx-like
utterances but when he began to be
exhibited in Paris in the last decades
of the of the 19th century and younger
artists emerging artists began to write
up his Apocrypha began to visit him and
began to transform him into to what we
now know him as which is the sort of
father or the primitive as they put it
of modern art there's a sort of
collected series of sayings that are
attributed to say-so on which we can
either find in his letters or in these
apocryphal collections let's talk about
Einstein a little bit
tell us how I'm Stein's work is related
to say Zhaan's work okay Einstein is
usually related to modern art through a
kind of popularization of the
mathematics the non-euclidean
mathematics that Einstein relied upon
for his theories of relativity in which
were first published in 1905 a year
before Cezanne is death and then later
in 1915 usually the connection between
these sort of popularized versions of
non-euclidean geometry and so-called
fourth dimension which was the popular
version of of what would become known as
relativity the connection to art is made
through cubism first in 1911 the poet
Apollinaire
then the next year in 1912 when ii went
in to cubist followers of Picasso and
Braque the painters glaze and met met
Sanjay wrote up a book called cubism in
which they related cubism to the fourth
dimension and to the geometry that was
created by Riemann so usually when we
think of relativity and a kind of
watered down version of Einstein's ideas
and modern art we think of cubism I want
the contact ok and why do you want to do
that because I actually because partly
because of the the the way in which
Cezanne like Einstein stands as a kind
of revolutionary figure who
revolutionized his field just design
Stein revolutionized his field but also
because of I think that some of the the
less well understood aspects of vines
dynein relativity correspond better to
the look of cézanne's
pictures so for example the non
Euclidean geometry that Einstein was
looking at was really a geometry of
curved space which it applies much
better to the kind of undulations the
focus on round objects on a space that
sort of keeps flowing and moving which
corresponds a little bit better to the
curved space of of relativity because
also Cezanne spaces are once in which
time and space come together so that
instead of the picture corresponding to
a single instant in time which had been
the the sort of classical idea of what a
pictorial space was you have a picture
which corresponds to an eye which keeps
moving in time shifting from one point
of view to another point of view to
another point of view in always in
motion which is I think much closer to
the
you the sense of what happens in
relativity which is you have multiple
viewers who and the time space-time
continuum that Einstein speaks of is
really in relation to a series of
viewers who have different vantage
points and are moving at different rates
relative to each other hence relativity
and I think that corresponds better to
what happens in what I would call the
space-time of saisons
paintings if you had to pick one of
cézanne's paintings as your favorite
what would it be and why
oh dear well I would pick a one of his
still lives and this is a book that
really does correspond to his two
focuses on that genre and I suppose I
don't have one single favorite painting
but there's a kind of culminating very
famous still life called the apples in
the world and oranges which is a very
luscious painting which does everything
that I've just described sort of in
spades there are multiple vantage points
there are a kind of proliferating world
of objects sort of rolling about in a
space which won't stay put which keeps
moving and which keeps curving and
shifting around those different objects
so that would be one of my my picks for
a favorite Cezanne okay and when will
say Zhaan's gravity be available well I
probably not before another couple of
years I'm sort of nearing the end of the
of the first draft of the book and that
it will have to be go through edits and
and so on well we will look forward to
seeing that then thank you so much for
being here with us today
thank you again for more information
about professor Armstrong please visit
our website at Yale edu slash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McNeil
rapport made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale